so why do you think it is that so many
members of the white community
uh have gone along with this i mean it
would be one thing to say you know back
in 1965
uh that huge swaths of americans had
acknowledged their guilt because they
had in fact been complicit in racism i
was born in 1984 so i was born 20 years
after the civil rights act and uh i i
frankly don't feel
racial guilt because i don't believe
that i've acted in racially intolerant
ways but you see huge swaths of
particularly young white americans
who are going along with this and and
brow beating
and and browbeating others engaging in
malice struggle sessions in which they
confess their own guilt for complicity
in a systemically racist system what
what do you think is the attraction for
white americans
to go along with the narrative where
they are inherently the victimizers
what happened in to white america when
that when america confessed
it's it's it's wrongdoing
is that america endured at that moment a
tremendous
loss of moral authority
when you and it's just human when when
you confess
i did it all right i'm sorry well okay
now you will pay a price um
uh and and that that is and that is what
happened to white america
is that they they were judged
to be racist they they had colluded with
evil and so now
they lived under the accusation that
they were racist
and that they had been a part of this
and so
they made they didn't may have done
absolutely nothing to justify
uh feeling guilty whatsoever it's white
guilt
has no connection whatsoever to personal
feelings
uh it is a it is a circumstance
that you are living in a society that
does not trust you
that has this against you that holds
this history
against you that uh and so
what do what what whites then have to
struggle for and have since the 60s
is their innocence of racism of proving
oh
not me i'm not a racist uh and
that that need to prove um
is what blacks take advantage of uh
okay then then do this and do that and
so forth and so on and change your
curriculum here and and uh uh start an
hr pro
uh uh program there have another so
forth and so on
uh and whites do it because they want
that innocence they want to be able to
say look
i supported affirmative action i'm all
for it let's
uh let's uh i support diversity let's
have different colored faces on
in everything we do so that we can prove
we are
innocent of that historical accusation
that we are evil racists anything
anything to get away from that
and so you know that one race begins to
enable
another race we have a sort of a
symbiotic
connection uh whites exploiting blacks
all over again in order this time
to capture some recapture some innocence
and power uh blacks sort of selling
themselves
out to guilty whites in order to ex
to have the illusion that victimization
is
is their power and so forth uh so it
gets to be a kind of
sad symbiosis that we are caught in
and uh we never honestly talk about it
but we're all nervous about it we're all
nervous
and and we all hope for the best i think
but it is history is powerful
um and america is
has a very unique history we're far far
ahead of
much of the rest of the world in this
regard
um but we we have a long way to go
it seems like there's something else
that has happened here too and that's
not just that uh
there's an attempt by both you know
guilty whites and uh
and and some black americans to push for
particular policy prescriptions and
sort of gimmies um but there's something
now that's going on that's completely
i think unprecedented which is that
you're only declared to be
not racist for a certain period of time
if you acknowledge your racism
so in other words if you say as a white
person i'm not racist
i'm i'm colorblind and i i see everybody
as an individual this is in fact used as
evidence of your racism
whereas if you then declare that you are
in fact a racist by dents of the color
of your skin and through racial
essentialization then you are not racist
but you are also racist because you just
acknowledged that you're racist so it's
a complete catch-22 there's literally no
way for white americans to escape
the charges of racism either you admit
that you're a racist in which case we
say
okay well at least you were honest
enough to admit you're a racist but that
means you're kind of a racist because
you just admitted it
or you won't acknowledge your own racism
in which case we absolutely 100
know that you're a racist that's right
uh and that power the power to put
whites in that position
is what is is what black power is is the
power that comes
from our from our moral authority as
victims as historical victims
uh and so we enjoy sort of squeezing
whites and
and uh in this in this impossible uh
this impossible circumstance uh but it
helps
again obviously whites
do not have at this moment in america
i'm speaking broad
broad terms here whites do not have the
moral
confidence to resist this
to say hey call me a racist whatever you
want
i believe this i stand by this
uh and i'll argue on the on the terms of
whatever it is i
i stand by i'm not going to be i'm not
going to be blackmailed intimidated
uh about the about simply being white
and simply having a a connection to
people in the past who are also white
uh does not mean that i am evil
uh and that i am a racist if you can't
accept that
too bad whites simply do not in america
have the moral
confidence to do that to say that that's
why we're stuck
when whites begin to rediscover their
confidence
and accept the fact that they are not
racists uh and that they want
to treat everybody as individuals and
they practice that
race problem be over black power will be
over
we'll have to take victimization and go
home it doesn't work anymore
right now it's just white's just this
morning amazon uh
castle the film that i i just
am coming out with uh just as they gave
10 million
dollars to black lives matter and other
um
left-wing black groups uh
well that's white guilt they don't
they don't believe in the money that
they gave they don't they have no they
don't care what
they they do with it with the money uh
they are buying their own innocence
they're saying
our brand is not racist
if you give money to shelby steele or
you just even put his
his uh his film up on on your platform
you're a bigot you're a racist you're a
horrible person
um so forth well
i suffer today from the lack of
confidence
that whites have that now is a big
problem in my life
and in my work i have someone who grew
up
fighting against segregation now i'm
fighting against it all over again
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content